[Música]
Bienvenidos a la crónica de medio
ambiente yo soy María Clara calle y Hoy
estamos desde guaviare un departamento
en el sur de Colombia donde desde hace
cuatro años la Unión Europea y también
la embajada de Francia respaldan la
implementación del proceso de paz y para
eso financiaron un proyecto llamado
caminemos territorios sostenibles en el
que promueven proyectos amigables con el
medio ambiente como la ganadería Silva
pastoril y la producción de frutos no
maderables de la selva amazónica como el
copo azul y el asaí Y esto es clave
porque guaviare es el tercer
departamento con la mayor tasa de
deforestación de Colombia han talado más
de 25.000 hectáreas en 2021 veamos
guaviare es conocido como la puerta de
entrada de la amazonía colombiana porque
queda al borde del bioma amazónico que
incluye siete departamentos y más de
50.000 hectáreas deforestadas la tala
para temas como la ganadería extensiva o
los cultivos de uso i se acercan cada
vez más a los territorios protegidos
como la reserva indígena de los nukamaku
de hecho la serranía del chiribiquete
fue el único Parque Nacional de Colombia
donde la deforestación aumentó en 2021
al incrementar un 13%. y para frenar la
deforestación 435 familias hacen parte
de caminemos territorios sostenibles y
de otro proyecto llamado terramás veamos
sus historias
estos jóvenes están convencidos que
produciendo frutos amazónicos frenarán
la tala de bosques con guaviare le
enseña sus 50 socios productores que las
plantas nativas de la amazonía sí pueden
ser rentables la idea es es ganarle la
batalla a la deforestación se
identifican esas especias como el
moriche de las hay entonces pues el
campesino si ve que va a recibir una
regalía de eso pues lo va a cuidar y con
esa protección también defienden los
corredores naturales del jaguar es una
especie sombrilla Qué significa eso él
es el tomador de decisiones en el
ecosistema y él es el que mantiene el
ecosistema sano eso lo primero que hay
que entender pero no es una pelea fácil
en guaviare la deforestación se disparó
desde 2017 tras la firma del acuerdo de
paz con la antigua guerrilla de las FARC
como uno lo siente en el territorio
antes era más complicado de entrar y
talar porque hay unos grupos irregulares
y ellos eran los que de una u otra forma
controlaban cuando ellos salieron
sin embargo Eduardo y otros 23 jóvenes
del departamento le apuestan a
transformar frutos como el ceje el asaí
o el moriche para venderlos su fuerte es
aprovechar el fruto convirtiéndolo en
pulpa y en harina para galletas y
mermeladas y también en aceite por el
que les han hecho ofertas de compra de
industrias cosmetológicas en España e
Italia y este aceite es muy bueno así
para el tema de la piel también apuestan
por la reforestación esperan sembrar
30.000 árboles nativos incluyendo el
cocoazú un cacao amazónico este vivero
tiene más de 250 mil plántulas y aquí es
donde viene lo bonito de lo que nos
dedicamos a hacer
que es devolverle al Bosque lo que les
traemos Además del copo azul en este
departamento amazónico de Colombia
también hay cacao Jairo tiene 2,5
hectáreas sembradas con las que produce
entre 1800 y 2000 kilos cuando yo llegué
acá este terreno estamos parados había
coca sembrada inclusive yo cuando llegué
la trabajé pero después con un proyecto
de familias guardabosques eso era del
gobierno
sustituir la coca la clave del arranque
y siempre ha cacao el que lo que vemos
ahí Jairo también ha sembrado más de
5000 árboles para ayudar a reforestar la
selva otros campesinos como Viviana
continúan con el ganado la actividad de
la que más pobladores dependen en
guaviare Pero ella se cambió el sistema
silvo pastoril por lo que en vez de un
gran Potrero tiene nueve más pequeños en
los que rota a las reses como era un
Potrero espléndido Entonces el ganado
así haciendo desperdi paso a paso porque
no se lo comían todo entonces se hacían
sino pisarlo Y entonces ahorita con las
divisiones en la rotación se ve más el
aprovechamiento O sea que cuando usted
tiene aquí el ganado en este potrerito
ya los a los pasan al otro y entonces ya
hay comida hay fresca esa rotación ayuda
que las vacas den más leche y aumenta el
rendimiento de la carne Viviana también
es beneficiada del tratamiento de agua
con caminemos territorios sostenibles
así pasó de consumir agua lluvia que
luego hervía al tener un filtro y a
sacar el suministro de un pozo que
construyeron en abril de 2021 y cuando
nosotros llegamos Pues en muchos de sus
hogares niños con enfermedades
diarreicas intestinales
Hay que ser también el objetivo como
organización como fundación pues no solo
brindarle el agua sino brindarle un agua
segura a las comunidades la energía con
la que el pozo succiona el agua sale de
cuatro paneles solares y así explotan el
campo de una manera sostenible
pero En qué consisten caminemos
territorios sostenibles y cómo es Su
financiación Y cuánto dinero han dado
para esta región de la amazonía
colombiana Aquí les explicamos
convivir con el bosque amazónico sin
talarlo para ampliar la ganadería ese
cambio de mentalidad lo promovió
caminemos territorios sostenibles un
proyecto promovido por Francia aplicado
por la ong andina y financiado en su
mayoría con los 6,2 millones de euros
del fondo europeo para la paz
pero el cambio no es fácil en guaviare
en los años 50 autoridades de tierras
exigieron convertir bosques en potreros
para titular siempre se dice el culpable
la ganadería pero la Por qué la
población que vive en ese sector toma la
ganadería Porque lastimosamente es el
único producto que él puede tener y coge
una vaca le Amarra un lazo y le haya
cualquier centro poblado y alguien se la
compra
desde 2018 caminemos financió 400
proyectos en guaviare para implementar
el proceso de paz y a la vez proteger la
amazonía por ejemplo promoviendo sistema
silvo pastoriles en los que las reses se
mueven entre potreros pequeños o
aprovechar el bosque para producir
frutos no maderables y beneficio de 242
ex combatientes de la antigua guerra ya
de las FARC pues partió entender lo que
necesitan los habitantes
revisión que tenemos es la f de no es
poner a la amazonía bajo una campana no
la idea es pues admitir que a gente que
vive en este territorio que también
tienen necesidades económicas para salir
adelante y cómo es que unimos las dos
cosas el interés del desarrollo
económico pero pues sostenible con el
medio ambiente lo que mostró caminemos
es la importancia de unir esfuerzos
locales e internacionales en torno a un
mismo objetivo y ahora que el proyecto
terminó la idea es que sus resultados
entren a la economía después de cuatro
años de proyecto vamos a realmente
considerar como la prioridad es
este este estos proyectos productivos en
no solamente de hecho la economía local
sino la economía colombiana otra de las
apuestas es aprovechar el cambio de
mentalidad que logró caminemos respecto
al cuidado del Bosque para que más
organizaciones internacionales trabajen
sobre ello Y a partir de ahí es que
llegamos con teramás y podemos potenciar
esos cambios de chips que se generaron
con camino eso es justo lo que aprovecha
tierra más un proyecto en el que el
gobierno francés invirtió 9,5 millones
de euros para combatir la deforestación
en Ecuador Colombia Perú y Brasil este
surgió de los 100 millones de euros que
prometió Emanuel en 2019 tras los
incendios en la selva brasileña en
guaviare terramás apoya a 35 familias
basándose en las enseñanzas de caminemos
el gobierno para nosotros es un
departamento importante bueno primero
porque es la puerta de entrada a la
selva amazónica Pero también es
un territorio que ha sido muy afectado
por el conflicto ambos proyectos han
trabajado con fortland creado por la ong
internacional el software permite
rastrear la deforestación por
geolocalización y también planificar
empezamos a construir con ellos Cuál
sería la estrategia de intervención para
planificar en el mediano en el corto y
en el largo plazo que va a ser su finca
y cuál es la conectividad de esta
cantidad de fincas y del vecindario para
una Vereda y para un municipio ahí
aparece por lado como una herramienta
para poder tomar decisión Fernando
mostró que las 12.260 hectáreas que
firmaron acuerdos de conservación con
caminemos y Terra más se disminuyó en 7%
la tasa de deforestación
y desde guaviare despedimos nuestra
Crónica de medio ambiente Vean este y
todos nuestros episodios en nuestro
canal de YouTube y en francés 24.com nos
vemos
[Música]